Starbucks do you read me we're under  attack from Ambrose's army we need your  help immediately we'll take the job and  Ross won't be getting his way this time  Landmaster deploy  stay charged box all units stay low  that's as far as you go star fox star  wolf why am I not surprised you're good  but not good enough  hot I the top  what's that it appears to be a  teleporter I'm able to pinpoint your  location due to lingering effects from  the space-time war nothing like a  challenge let's take it down look alive  it's time for the main event starfox  we've located one of Ambrose's four  holes will you help us you count on it  Andrews won't get away with this  alright boys let's rock and roll  do a barrel roll  walk